[Music]
hi everybody I'm Dave Stassen alongside
Geoff Worthing and welcome to the annual
east/west bowl as we get ready to watch
some of the best college players in the
nation showcase their skills in a
classic showdown between east and west
and there really are some characters on
this year's squads aren't there Jeff
that's right David does seem like the
most flamboyant personalities came to
the forefront and they are here let's
meet the players from the east
[Music]
DeMarcus Williams University of Georgia
CJ Justin Wayne State University Tavares
myth king merrimack college Tom oils
smoochie-wallace university Miami disc
warious green jr. University of Notre
Dame ibrahim moizoos university of
tennessee at chattanooga jack marius tax
era tricks michigan state university the
isaiah t billings chloride Coastal
Carolina University
the Jeff for probing Kruk the third
South Carolina State University leoz
maxwell jr east carolina university
Jabbar's to Marge virus and Lamar
University of Middle Tennessee the voice
our handle University of Southern
Mississippi hingle mccringleberry penn
state university
no carpet Ron Duke Mary Florida Atlantic
University ridiculous Morgan University
of South Florida ex miss Jackson flaxen
waxing California University of
Pennsylvania
we're going to be looking for big plays
all game long from tyroil
smoochie-wallace and let's not forget
the tight ends ibrahim moizoos and
hingle mccringleberry they've both had
amazing season that's right chef now
let's meet the players from the West
vegetarian jefferts bed check the say mm
the cluster how da catcher University of
Wisconsin swore Pathan L good and splat
saskatchewan university Quatro Quatro
San Jose State University ozamataz
buckshank stanford university visa 12
washing beard Jones college
Shakira Quan TGIF Carter university of
northern Arizona
X Wayne at Alysha sness Missouri Western
State University sequester Brundle Plitt
MD Adam state scores philosoraptor
Malloy's South Dakota State University
TJ AJ RJ backslashes fourth the fifth
albion college San Diego State
University donkey teeth Boise State
University torque
Lewis Nevada State Penitentiary the
player formerly known as Mouse cop
University of missouri-columbia Dan
Smith BYU I'm Dave Stassen alongside
Geoff Worthing and welcome to the 2013
east/west bowl where we're going to be
watching some of the best college
athletes in the nation
try to put last year's spectacle to
shame that's right Dave it won't be easy
but this year's seniors certainly will
be trying to give last year stars a run
for their money let's check out the
team's starting with the players from
the east
Koz Nestor Smith Rutgers University
ellipses quarter University of Alabama
now ik will instill wide LSU there's no
fun yen's Florida State University you
cut that like mango
George I checked university mergatroid
skittle University of Louisville
Krishna Todd business University of
Tennessee compares poop share Oh miss
quackadilly blip auburn university
Julius Boozer the you Muscatine triskin
University of Michigan far trail plugins
University of Arkansas wrong Washington
cartoons plural virginia tech jammie
jammie-jammie the ohio state university
further
some of the big stories this year the
meteoric rise of d'pez poopsie and let's
not forget about heisman winner jammie
jammie-jammie and remember you can't
talk about 2013 without bringing up
fudge everybody's talking about fudge at
350 pounds this running back is almost
unstoppable the whole year you're right
I can talk about fudge all day but first
let's meet the players from the West
[Music]
Quan ducklings Indiana university-purdue
University Indianapolis DA historians
llama stories Utah State University
Ewok Onias and Goran a--the jr. steam
Oklahoma State University exquisite team
bublé's Winslow University of Nebraska
who Calaca nakka nakka nakka you can
local Okaka FACA
University of Hawaii King Prince
chambermaid Baylor University the denna
furture dynasty University of Colorado
da da da da da da da da da da da la da
da da da da da da da University of
Arizona Harvard University DeVry
University baby surplus store wing-dings
online classes first-name lastname
College University God homeschool Santa
Monica College
Benedict Cumberbatch Oxford University
hey ron balakay morehouse college
[Music]
ager dinkle edge Yallah carpet ride
check out leoz I wonder what he's
dreaming about he is probably dreaming
about what we is gonna do to the team in
the West I wonder to various myths t
King for sure I'm a bad man magenta and
awful Sport smoothly wireless you can
call me ty royal wrapping up rushes like
aluminum foil between best be wary the
carpet Ron - Marian I love the ball so
much I want to marry
[Music]
we gonna show
we are the best I'm into Brahim boys ooh
my rhymes are clean like my name was dr.
Seuss with my shower here that's my name
power candles sounds the same with Jack
and Harry thus we're ready to borrows
from the mall dr. Watson played sax
after Marcus played guitar
[Music]
okay don't you know
in didi be our best
[Music]
cuz ya'll one-member this awesome
y'all ready Dan Smith Smith comma Daniel
other kickin lead all the candle
cheerleaders up I'm a talking cross
who's got their baby cocker spaniel BYU
Bayou beat back as the bitch won again
with me got swisher Sweets and nuts he's
rollin and um some team Kentucky's hit
and field girls blunted been drunk when
I planted better like that hundred times
that I've already done it Oh see these
haters thought I was playing staying
away from my face with honor when you
tossing those gauntlet some Dan Smith
and the West is getting rowdy like must
[Applause]